we're totally cool they go yeah go you
go
I go yeah you're listening to the dollop
on the all things comedy Network this is
an American history podcast each week I
vote Ryder when we on about last carrot
eater is going on already bathroom rug
owner Dave Anthony oh my god
reads a story from American history to
his friend Gareth Reynolds who has no
idea what the topic is going to be about
you know what's funny is I remember I
was on a boat and you might be like
three months ago yes I don't know if
that's an active thing I remember one
time when we did a live show and
afterwards we went and we got a bite
with a buddy of yours and we were
talking about the bit where you say all
the things and I was like it had a good
run and I was being genuine I was like
we had a good run with it that was a
year ago
and you were just looking at me like not
you know not going like yeah I think
it's almost over you were definitely
like silent just sort of being like yeah
remote control user yeah and called it
quote is jam-packed I'm the [ __ ] guy
Dave okay Gary but it's good is it for
five and this is not gonna come
particularly podcast yeah now hit him
with the puppy you both was that sick
argument
I remember some of those - like how my
phone does that what you didn't notice
we're gonna show you you don't care what
yeah I don't care what you guys we're
gonna be on tour we're gonna have lots
of tour lots of times we'll be in Salt
Lake City
coming up on the 20th of July and then
the next night we'll be in Denver on the
21st after that in August Minneapolis on
the 17th 16th is sold out
Nashville you're sold out they'll be in
Cleveland we'll be in Pittsburgh we'll
be in Washington DC Boston Royal Oak
Michigan Chicago Dallas Austin Christ
those are all on sale and then we're
also just announced our Australian tour
oh my god we'll be going to Perth
Brisbane Adelaide Byron Bay Canberra
Sydney Melbourne Canberra Hobart
hopefully hopefully Hobart I mean you
think everybody knows hopefully
everybody knows by now that we are we're
booking into a venue that is currently
on strike so if the employees are still
in strike we'll figure something else
but we're not gonna cross big line we'll
do it at one of their houses dude
seriously we will we will no matter what
people get a show it just might be in a
park or something but I'm not I'm not
doing the show I'm not crossing a picket
line so yeah I will go to dog park Escom
all the tour stuff is there and you can
click on all the links to get tickets
and stuff there do you have dates you
want to say I know you like to say dates
I'm going on a lot of dates with Dave we
have suppers know you I I have some
stuff coming up I'm on a little dollop
we're doing more dollop dates coming up
but then I'll pick back up by so you can
go to Gareth Reynolds calm if you have
any curiosity about what those are like
and boy did I have some fun
if you're a fan of the dollop which I
assume you are because you're listening
you might enjoy mysteries like mysteries
I don't know if so let me tell you it
was asked about a new podcast I love me
called
unexplained mysteries every week the
hosts itch look into the greatest
mysteries of the past and present like
for the building of Stonehenge which you
probably don't know anything about I do
know everything about it it's a bunch of
weird rocks as done by Druids druids who
took out oh yeah and that or just the
Mona Lisa how what happened with Mona
Lisa how'd that get done yeah that's it
coolest like stuff that you're like oh I
know that thing I know the deal with
that she was smiling real big now they
may not be simple answers or
explanations but that doesn't mean
there's no explanation at all yeah so
they dig into the investigate the
Earth's greatest mystery each episode
it's great storytelling which I know
people this podcast like so you go
through a little journey how they got to
the greatest mystery sure the team
researchers which we could use yeah the
hosts use in-depth research and analysis
while they might try to find out the
answers so I check out episodes on the
majestic 12 the Mona Lisa and Stonehenge
now and with a new episode coming out
every Thursday you can expect a new
mystery every or maybe not every
Thursday there's an apple podcast tuned
Spotify Google Play or wherever you
listen to podcasts and search for
unexplained mysteries a gun that's
unexplained mysteries you and you said
exon there's not a tell is that a clue
did I say gun you said a gun
no I didn't that's a clue isn't it and
expl a I and II D my ste RI es the Manas
but or visit par cast calm slash
unexplained and start listening now
that's part cast p AR c AR st.com slash
unexplained part cast nice part of cast
no do not use it at all no I think that
might be a thing nope part park no power
nope that's how my dad used to say my
mom's name ha yeah
we're also sponsored by Casper more
mysteries as the ghost and the mattress
yeah
my listeners are invited to take
advantage of Casper's competitive the
limited time fourth of July offer so
that's right for the July's coming up so
that's seriously limited time yeah hurry
Casper's a place to shop before the July
mattress savings this year they sell
directly to you allow your independence
from a bad mattress they sell directly
to you oh I get it yeah it's in getting
a defense from a bad mattress good with
good mattress yeah yeah it's
Independence Day they sell directly to
you eliminating added costs and savings
saving you money you like to save money
right no no no I'm the opposite you can
be sure your purchase with Casper's a
hundred night risk-free sleep on it
trial and returns are hassle-free if
you're not completely satisfied so
that's cool you can just get it back via
original Casper mattress combines
multiple supportive memory foams for a
quality sleep service with the right
amounts of both sink and bounce and I
know you like it sink breathable design
of each mattress helps you sleep cool
and regulate your body temperature
throughout the night it's a great
mattress um you got you yeah you sleep
on one I sleep I sleep in one yeah
interesting I've made some adjustments
okay I'm uncomfortable you just read in
it keep reading the guy that comes out
of the box ya know I've talked about I
would like to buy one once a week just
to watch it come out or yeah I'll just
go to people's places when they open it
and then just leave anyways it's like
but I yeah you guys should get one cuz
they're comfortable I sleep well and
you'll sleep in any listener that orders
one Dave will come over and sleep in it
tonight you know sleeping they'll break
it in yeah for a live at a time visit
Casper comm slash savings and save up to
two hundred and twenty five dollars off
your order limited time only this
special offer expires July ninth 2018
terms and conditions apply so it's a
little bit after it's a little you gotta
get your days to recover and get in
front a few days after Independence Day
okay we're also brought to you by
Birdwell Beach britches we both now own
we're owners we wear them around well we
with some his fashion shows and each
other's houses yes and by the way people
are like is it a show if it's just you
and another guy who's also doing it yeah
it is absolutely we have a light kit
yeah the whole there's music yeah it is
a show people are doing stuff summer's
here and the beach pool and lake are
calling a wondering what to wear this
year Gareth no I know
forget about flash-in-the-pan trends and
guesswork and get classic surf style
from Birdwell that will look good year
after year yeah it's the kind of thing
difficult doesn't go out of style
there's been an awesome just look you
look awesome you look awesome
gosh I love your fall look thank you
they're legendary for their quality
birdies our customers often come in to
Birdwell Santa Ana factory and store in
the same pair of birdies they've been
wearing store sorry I said soar into the
star and the same papers have been
wearing for years decades sometimes
sometimes 30-plus years yeah sometimes
people pass them down in their family
like it'll be someone's dad's shorts
well my dad has given me a lot of shorts
shirts shirts sorry birdies are
purpose-built for surfing originally
developed for surfers carry birdwell's
sons the lady it's actually named after
Birdwell Birdwell beach britches were
purposely built for all the rigors of
surfing about perfect for any activity
under the Sun so like if you want to
like um just slowly jog in the beach and
then we'll just kind of do some back
flips in the lake yeah that they work
for that Birdwell Beach breeches pure
Southern California and classic surf
style they got 56 years behind them very
well Beach breeches are part of the
fabric of the Golden Age of Southern
California surf culture just like the
Beach Boys hot rods skateboarding and my
dog do you 10% off your first Birdwell
Beach breeches purchase with lifetime
guarantee and free shipping over $99 go
to Birdwell calm and use discount code
dollop a check out that's discount code
DOL o P at Burt real calm pick up your
first pair birdies and see why they've
been that American icon since 1961 and
the jackets I'm telling you go look at
the jackets you go look at the jacket
you've got looked at the jackets know
the hope that's go jackets of course
yeah yeah I told you I know why
why does it have to be a competition I'm
better than you so it's not fair fair
answer so it's not a competition good
answer because I'm better than good
answer
can't fault the guy for a good answer
not docking any points for a good answer
thanks for bathing today what's your
deal I'm just not used to it
what is it why do you have this why do
you perpetuate these rumors I'm very
clean 1765 okay
you're like a town crier now had to lean
back a debuff myung-bak respectful of
the years of the listeners your deep
off-mike what's your deal and ruin
Elizabeth Jackson arrived from Ireland
in America into America sweet sending
country of America they were very poor
very poor
yes I'll never go poorly oh [ __ ] we left
the potatoes they lived in Waxhaw a
settlement named after the Waxhaw tribe
sure the settlement was along the north
and south north south carolina border
kind of right there straddles that bad
boy okay after two years though Andrew
died well he tried to lift up a log and
he hurt himself and got sick and he died
from lifting up a log I mean we really
are in charm times it was you lifting up
a lot which is something you had to do
yeah yeah you had to lift up a log
intentionally no you'd ever know unless
you're Richard to lift up the log there
was no die not lifting logs man yeah
that was it at the funeral his neighbors
got was someone appalled Baron like my
back you see oh no at the funeral his
neighbors got shit-faced and put his
coffin on a mule drawn sled sure sure
and when the sled arrived at the
cemetery everyone realized the coffin
was gone so they retraced their sled
steps so the wild sledding didn't get
the body there know that we often
snagged on a branch of a tree in that
well David I mean certainly crazy that
branches were involved in yeah I'm just
saying sometimes my average people are
stereotypical yeah yeah thinking so
there are two boys right
Elizabeth and the boys moved in with her
sister and brother-in-law in under a
month on March 15th 1767 Andrew Jackson
was born Oh No you know that name
yeah old old chair old Cherokee yeah
sure
what does he know
angry at Cherokee he Old Hickory agree
up that's you live with his mom and
loser yeah that's right
how old is he right now he's a baby
loser okay I don't know why come on get
out of the house you loser just got porn
get a job you dumb ass Jesus come on Oh
Cherokee
do you live with his mom his aunt uncle
for the first 10 to 12 years of his life
his Aunt Jane was an invalid so Andrews
mom took care of all the kids she had
three and I started eight she took care
of 11 kids Jesus which is lots I would
just say why didn't the log take me yeah
that's when you start lifting there
that's how you tried to kill yourself by
throwing a few logs around aside federal
law and go please take me sorry Lord
come on log God Lord and it was said to
always be doing pranks and getting in
trouble okay prankster yeah a slave on
the farm said Andrew was treated for a
disease she called the big itch hmm what
is no that's all we got oh boy
quote there is two inches the big itch
and a little itch the little itch ain't
nothing to the big itch the big itch
breaks out all you over and do frighten
a body powerful so he's got like in a
full body rash yeah he sounds like he
had a bad one Oh like a look at me like
you're bleeding scratching guys sure
right it was also reported than Andrew
suffered from an unknown disease that
caused quote slobbering okay wait are we
sure that he's not some sort of like
wild shaved dog that's him but maybe
some Rashed up like that's our boy okay
so he's so he's pink with rash and
slobbering no that's our boy slobber
tender playing pranks who put saran wrap
over the outhouse
I don't know that so itchy it's me oh
not yes young Hickman right now you just
love her Andy regular Hickory he became
a bully okay he was described as quote
self-willed somewhat overbearing easily
offended very ear accessable and upon
the whole difficult to get along with
okay so we have an enormous newborn
gerbil skin tone slobbering who's tough
to be around super hot right yeah it's a
good vibe he also enjoyed swearing and
was known often to say by God which I
guess was a swear word but come on yeah
come on I think we say worse he also
wasn't very interested in he wasn't
interested in school or reading okay
finally I'm understanding yeah now I get
inside the head of this guy hundred
percent as her sons grew Elizabeth
taught them to fear and hate Native
Americans good good start
mmm-hmm until you do that yeah at the
time there were roving bands of Native
Americans who attacked whites so all the
kids were taught to always be aware to
notice unusual movements in the forest
and other fun child survival tactics
right yeah that's fun for a kid yeah and
if you didn't then you could get killed
yeah well you know yeah well that's what
happens when you discover land that was
already someone already lives there yeah
well happy well well well this will be
lovely move you crack yeah when Eider
was 12 his older brother went to fight
in the Revolutionary War that's the one
against the British we don't know that's
where we tossed your people out listen
we're not willing this is kind of a will
we won't we sort of deal
Chris Trent and I we have a real pig
aside it's all I'm saying we have a real
will they won't they pick us real Ross
Rachel because I I've picked both sides
he died after a battle of heat and
fatigue so he fought in a battle and
then afterwards like I'm hot
I'm losing the Battle of a sudden yeah
they probably I forgot the stuff called
water yeah right
well they had meat or something so the
Jacksons were Whigs and supported
American independence on May 29th 1780
300 militia on horseback attacked the
Waxhaw settlement okay
they killed 113 people and wounded 150
Robert and Andrew helped their mother
treat the wounded soldiers okay mm-hmm
nice subtle is he still slobbering at
that I don't know if he was slobbering
anymore I know he was if you still got
like a hooch mouth and I don't know if
you want him over some sort of open
wound or I would imagine when he got
nervous eh so well it's not what you
want from the guy he's got sutures no
five stitches the settlement was
attacked twice more that year and his
family would move north when the attacks
happen both boys want to enlist but they
were too young to fight them so they
served as Scouts and couriers okay and
when his brother were captured by the
British and taken to a prison camp in
South Carolina okay their wounds were
not treated because they got hit in the
head and stuff when they were getting
captured okay because they got captured
kind of her mouthing off they were being
like Jericho's yeah the food was off to
jail so they the British had like jails
around well I think it's just like a
it's probably I would imagine a fence
right with dudes inside oh yeah and
you'll ring you reunite the families
eventually yeah yeah yeah the food was
bad and there was not much so it was
English like some bangers well the
potatoes half way cooked would you like
one
we've run out of salt about subside you
probably sounded you tighter
I'm gonna go without actually I'm good
look how hot the plate is that's nice
isn't it yes that is nice and that
hungry more broth more uncooked cause
[ __ ] I know can that is there a way I
can die is there a dying option well try
the beef
and it was robbed of his jacket and
shoes and then he got separated from his
brother and cousin okay and then
smallpox broke out I feel like Andrew
might have already had smallpox yeah
you're right or something worse what is
worse slobbering and itching right okay
yeah and his brother were started coming
down with smallpox now his mother I
don't know how this happened his mother
Elizabeth came and brokered a prisoner
exchange she talked to an American
captain into giving up 13 British and
then in return she got seven prisoners
okay two of whom were her sons okay
Robert was so sick she she had to walk
beside the horse and hold them up it was
a 40 mile journey home but he died
before they got home okay
Andrew was very very close to death and
he remained an invalid for several
months but it was Elizabeth nursed him
back to health and she decided at that
point to bring medicine and messages to
a prison ship in Charleston which is 160
miles away so there's a they were
putting all the prisoners on the ship in
Charleston okay and she found out about
it and she was I called bring him
medicine and she got the messages from
people around okay so now the hood sure
and then on the way back she was quote
seized with the ship fever and died
Jesus now he went to the ship and she
got the ship fever that's why you go to
ship go and save a little the save a
shot of medicine for yourself if you're
going there near the ship but you know
you're an active boater
I'm boat man yeah your boat yeah it was
by cholera I would imagine
or just one of the awesome ship disease
sure yeah [ __ ] barnacles or something
yeah yeah sure my gum particles yeah she
has barnacles on her yeah oh no so
Andrew now is at home alone dying of
smile he's okay he's recovered but he
just got sick like he takes a while he's
14 years old but he's got no family and
he was sure I mean he's got distant
relatives who he goes to live with you
know but they're not his yeah they're
not as cool about I was slobbering yeah
yeah they all think he's weird yeah
his health came back and then he got
into horse-racing gambling drinking and
cockfighting
finally he is back yes he went [ __ ]
over the top yeah
nice the Revolutionary War ended
congratulations America
the British were gone so that made it
needed Navi need new laws in America
right ones that would hold up throughout
any test yeah there's nothing that could
pop nothing that could shake the
foundation of these laws that they were
going to come up with right there's no
something that locks democracy and
forever no matter what right we're gonna
do those and then we're set and there's
nothing can shake that yep it's the
British yet yeah a little bit
so Andrew decided to become a lawyer to
take advantage of that sweet sweet
situation okay he studied with a couple
of lawyers one of whom had lost a hand
in the war and used a silver knob for a
promise about a prosthesis yeah yeah
he's just got it's a knob hand knob hand
yeah and so when he was arguing case he
would bang it on the table well that
really takes away the judges power
I am also banging stop banging your
weird knob and jump banging on the jury
box which I think would be pretty
effective yeah the judge jealous the
more I think yeah it's good is he just
took a door handle basically an answer
yeah knocking [ __ ] with yeah sure so the
judge Board of North Carolina superior
court of law
concluded Andrew was now ready to
practice law not for a little while okay
I was like a year maybe my shirt off so
he gets it no this is the time of duel
but he's also studying law that hasn't
necessarily been established yet so it's
probably kind of rush it's not great you
know you're like there's nine things to
know okay that's pretty quick course yes
take your syllabus go home come back
tomorrow ring BAM boom most likely
you're a lawyer let's do it all right
guilty perfect all right now for your
knob hand thank you
so a lot of duels and ER and ER was in
his share he enjoyed duels it was said
he had over 100 dolls but it sounds like
allows with just fights and not actually
shooting duels so a duel where you walk
away and then just throw punches for
twenty paces away from someone on your
fist yeah I would have hit you with this
get your fists ready ah then you wax and
gross and the guy's eyes and yeah sure
if you throw a bag up but what are those
that's
powder on the ground and a big cloud
comes up me and you run away yeah yeah
it's a duel but so those are maybe just
ones that go to the brink of I don't
know I don't know I think they just
called sometimes they call the fight a
duel and then it got confused after a
while that's stupid
yeah I hear ya in 1788 a friend of
Andrews was appointed as a Superior
Court judge in Western North Carolina
okay which today is known as Tennessee
okay sure
he appointed and her to be the
district's public prosecutor okay
they're around 5000 white people living
in Nashville but it was unsafe to live
outside of the central area because of
Native American attacks okay so once
there Andrew quote aided in pursuing and
chastising the enemy the Native American
yeah oh yeah yeah soon after arriving he
was involved in an attack on some
Cherokee Oh Cherokee was no he's not old
Cherokee his name make sense
definitely not Andrews commander said he
was quote bold dashing fearless and mad
upon his enemies and they had a great
deal he had a great ambition for
encounters with the savages okay so he
enjoyed fighting it sounds like he liked
just going [ __ ] ape [ __ ] BS yes
yeah made him slobbering all over his
slobberin and getting itchy yeah the
American government wanted peace talks
with the Native Americans Marren
governments like this so let's do let's
do the talky thing where we talk and
figure some stuff out sure Andrew
disagreed with that approach and wrote
to a friend quote peace talks are
nothing but delusions to put white men
off their guard and that experience
teaches us that treaties answer to no
other purpose than opening an easy door
for the Indians to pass through and
butcher our citizens so trees basically
just a door like a trap door situation
sure so there's not a lot of see if you
think about there's not a lot of not a
lot of options once you rule that one
out the talking part once you got the
talking part then there's kind of one
I think it's a policy that could still
work option
yeah I think that could still play for
us yeah I agree silence locking
ourselves in the bedroom yeah eating a
bucket of chicken I think that could
still play oh yeah yeah one of the
founders of Nashville had a daughter
named Rachel I found it that's it's
Nashville it's mine and I found it there
were already people there but yeah I get
it
it's mine get him out of here well
there's people living there in Nashville
get them out okay they're not from here
no they they are from here not anymore
let me see their IDs that's just
something I came up with no ID well then
they need to get out cuz they don't have
them I found it here fun what Nashville
it's this whole area here it goes from
there to there and then back to there in
the air it was already here now it's
Nashville I don't think you quite
understand the how I'm at venting
country line dancing Nashville get him
out get who out his people the people
who live here before you the people have
been living here for decades centuries
of gondor's of years all the time the
ones get him out why would I get him out
cuz they don't like country it's a lake
shelter the founder had a daughter named
Rachel who married a captain Robarts and
they lived in Kentucky but Robarts
became very jealous of a boarder in the
house they lived in he became jealous of
a border a border a guy who lived in out
of that border okay room and board
Porter not a guy made out of boards I
mean can I picture what I want yeah okay
so Rachel came back after he has a
temper so she didn't enjoy that part of
him so she came back to Tennessee to
live with her mother and then Robarts
came back and moved in with them okay
now this is the house the man made of
boards he's he go he got he caught on
fire okay well man that's terrible for
him yes what yeah it was not good so
Andrew Jackson came and this is the
family that he boarded with so he's
living with the mom he's the real bars
and right Raymer
he's the new Kramer I'll castrate
Robards then became jealous of Andrew
sure what's not to be jealous of his
rank he's frothing yes
great yeah when Andrew learned Robards
was telling people that he was too
intimate with his wife Andrew found him
and told them if he heard any of that
kind of talk again he would quote cut
his ears out of his head
Jesus so he goes cutting off is what you
do cutting out of his well that's like a
coring yeah exactly going in you're
getting a melon scooper because you can
just slice off an ear but inside the ear
each time about the whole inner ear
getting all the pumpkins whatever well I
don't know if they call it that but yeah
yeah yeah well I'm pretty familiar with
WebMD I think you're not cuz there's
actually no pumpkin seeds in it in a
human read on Robards then hire a head
and her arrest it because he threatened
him right hey and then a guard came in
took Andrew away and Robarts decided to
travel with him to the courthouse right
because they're taking him to the
courthouse I've had to deal with the
situation on the way Andrew talked the
guard into giving him his butcher knife
what guide the gardener knife I'm
assuming that this was a mistake that
someone wrote and it's just it's like a
real sweet talker I mean I don't know
look it's a knife I don't know why
you're rolling her but I don't know why
you're rolling around the country the
butcher knife just have a knife have a
turn take a rip well he talked about it
he talked him into giving him the
butcher knife by promising not to do any
harm with it he's like look I'm not
gonna do anything I just like holding
that the whole Times quote Jackson
examined the point in edge glancing the
while at Robards so he's holding the
knife and he's looking at Robards nice
hold the knife and then Robards just
starts running okay it's like this is
far so something about him looking at
the knife and looking at yeah his eyes
made him feel uneasy yeah probably I was
worried okay especially after he said
he's gonna cut his ears out of it yeah
yeah yeah I guess those might be you put
those together yeah yeah yeah yeah so
Jackson pursued him into the cane so
Jason yeah and then he came back alone
and and went went to the courthouse with
the guard on charges that were being
filed by a man who had that's
interesting so at the court without
why are you here yeah I don't know do
you want this knife it's pretty cool
no no but clearly yeah there was a guy
by you in the defendants box no comfy
is anyone pressing anything against you
no they're uh yeah no I think we're good
okay nice to see you yeah I was see you
there thank my knob a few times you guys
can get out of here yep
anyway Robards moved away without Rachel
after that oh so okay
Wow no charges case over Robarts goes
away cleared so now eventually andrew
learn Robards was granted a divorce from
Rachel
so now Rachel's single single and Andrew
okay so the rumors potentially were true
Yeah right yeah so he married her
they're both 24 two years later andrew
finds out that Rachel and Robarts
divorce had never been finalized you
actually needed a special act from the
the legislature which they didn't have
what like a duet yeah and Robarts hadn't
followed through with that so in 1794
Edward Rachel got a new marriage license
and remarried to make sure it was
official okay I'm not sure how that
works in fixes the first part of her
still being married to the other guy but
apparently well I think it's like you
know most recent yep so last last last
official second in yeah it's like your
last address yeah yeah so as a lawyer
andrew was known to not take much [ __ ]
okay once opposing counsel mocked one of
his legal arguments so he wrote out a
dual challenge and handed it to the guy
okay yeah right printed up sure and the
other guy was like yeah if I can do that
[ __ ] yeah okay was it like do you want
to do Olczyk yesboxx or no but I think
it was a yes or no box yeah or maybe
yeah yeah
or you did one of those little like
things you do this little that's gonna
be hard to convey at a podcast
was you listening or watching you know
I'm sure the ice sure like seven year
old girls could tell you the name of
that yeah okay where you got that little
trap in here yeah okay
so cut that out it so then the case
after a while the case was sent to the
jury and then the two lawyers went
outside into the street and held a duel
okay so so they are basically the the
lawyers who are opposing lawyers go
outside for a duel while the jury's
deliberating that's right
interesting yep it's interesting it's an
interesting scenario you know so they
both did the walkie walk and then they
turned and shot and they both missed and
then they walked over and shook hands
and we're again and we're good buddies
laughter that is the weirdest feature
that is weirdest thing about the duel
you would make a reload I mean I
understand but you think maybe have like
another another pistol on your hands you
get a second shot yes I can try then
maybe you shake hands it's sort of like
extra time in the way I would I would go
like four tries five tries me well then
you're definitely getting death I
wouldn't mind to to I mean but the but
the one where you're just like oh well
here we go there it was neither of us
killed the other pool I'd love to play
some pool yeah
so Andy travel all over Tennessee is a
lawyer usually with a small group of men
and they camp constantly they're always
under the threat of lawyers yeah that's
a new show on ABC
there was under threat of attack from
Native Americans he gained a reputation
as one of Tennessee's best Indian
fighters okay right Andrew practice law
history doesn't history frowns upon that
title yes yeah
Andrew practice law for eight years
sometimes he was given land as a payment
okay so sometimes I do a really good job
and they'd be like here's an acre
whatever just random acres I'm yeah I
mean where else something they can give
you the acre you want good well maybe I
mean wouldn't you want a bunch of acres
near each other yeah that's probably
better
rather than some sort of right now
acreage so we can go to my acre there's
nothing on it spend the weekend there I
mean it'd be cool they just have an acre
somewhere you know yeah
but they pile up and then you just have
a bunch of acres well maybe you just try
to get other acres that match up to it
just keep working hard dude it's not
monopoly my chicken cases take some
divorce cases you might get
so what interested you in our case well
the plot it's very close to a bunch of
makers I have that I'm trying to merge I
just would love to have them I'd love to
have a house have you considered getting
a divorce that I really think you should
you know she's sleeping with that man
who's made a board excuse me she's
sleeping with your guy who's made of
board yeah yeah we filmed that premature
hay boards her you know I'm talking
about all right well I'm gonna go to
your neighbors what a nightmare this has
been he also bought land when there are
not many settlers around some land he
also wanted in cockfights Wow
I mean this classic president stuff yeah
yeah I mean well you know in retrospect
he ended up with over 50,000 acres near
each other right what a life that's a
lot of land if it's close sometimes he
was given slaves as payment that's cool
cool person to cover that it's always
fun to remember that he got his first
slave in 1788 that's a big day getting
your first slave oh it's only a big day
tears later you received two more so
he's you know racking up the slaves in
the land during his first 15 years at
the national settlement a settler was
killed once every 10 days by Native
Americans Jesus so they're picking them
off right good so it's like an injury
chalkboard at restaurants not great
right in 1794 and it was one of 550
soldiers who killed quote a considerable
number of Cherokee warriors nice they
destroyed the Cherokee town of running
water it was the largest town of hostile
Cherokee and it basically ended the war
in the area okay they did a big old that
kill everybody right cool
yeah well I mean yeah like I think when
you really look back you know it's cool
yeah when I think I'm like right word
yeah we did cool things and cool stuff
to cool people yeah and we processed it
yeah yeah and it was really making a
name for himself he helped draft the
state constitution Wow and then became
the state's first representative in the
House of Representatives
so the first androgynous but it was a
studio apartment yeah seriously yeah he
got a 1113 boats his opponent got 12
what was his opponent a cactus board
instead he's a guy to me that board huh
oh man I thought more people would it
turned out you see my girl around
nothing's easy when you're made of
boards yes a song oh hi I didn't realize
you guys were there I thought I just
heard you singing well I was just
talking about how hard it is being made
of boards yeah everyone looks at you
when you're different made of wood yeah
you sit around and wonder yeah but maybe
could I'm just gonna take this nail
right here if you have been where and
all of a sudden I was God now kill me
get one in the head that hurts that
actually hurts yeah that's so cool
yeah I'm fine I'm mainly pine no one
knows what it's like when you're made of
pine oh you cuz I was different gotta
put a smile on your face pretend you're
feeling fine but you're not good so uh
so the militia who had attacked and
killed the Cherokee wanted compensation
for their war right so that when they're
in Washington they're like we should get
some money for all those people with you
and we're like we will always take care
of the veterans because we kill our own
Tribune's so we should get some cash we
should reward you they wanted 20 thick
2,816 dollars for expenses President
Washington was like no you know I mean
he was really more like no no no no
teeth mouth no mouth mouth out no
because he he didn't wanna pay him
because it wasn't a defensive battle it
was offensive so he's like well if you
guys are protecting yourself we could
pay up now see if one of them had
attacked you going out killing people
and that's different but he wrote all
this down with a yeah bloody yeah tooth
stub a Andrew went and I heard that she
says porridge sir when Andrew heard this
he lost his [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
Old Hickory & quot bolted to his feet on
the House floor he roared his rage he
insisted that the raids were just
unnecessary okay was looking at us funny
he had a bit of a temper yeah it seems
like never temper a committee was formed
in the house with a guy named Andrew
Jackson as the chairman
and now weirdly the committee then
recommended Tennessee be paid the money
mm-hmm and then the bill passed and now
and there was an even bigger hair on
Tennessee well andrew is the only one
voting on it right he's still the only
guy in there it's just me yay-yay to
that the A's have it three months later
the Senate seat a Senate seat opened up
and he was appointed okay he worked as a
senator from November 1797 to April 1798
and then he resigned okay this is short
sure banged out like six months sure any
reason he didn't like it I didn't like
it I don't like the job sure he wasn't
big on politics and sitting around no
yes well and compromise and all that
stuff right some presidents aren't when
I got back he was elected to the
Tennessee Supreme Court he served on the
Supreme Court for six years in 1801 he
beat his nemesis John severe and became
Major General of the Tennessee militia
okay it was a very prestigious job sure
this is when people started calling him
General Jackson even though he he's a
major-general but calling Major General
is kind of boring or no long range just
cutting out in general mg mg yeah Andrew
did not have any biological children but
he had a shitload of kids you know the
rumors were true Rachel's brother died
in 1804 and ander became the guardian of
his three sons John Samuel Andrew
Jackson Andrew Jackson and Daniel Smith
okay now they were 6 5 & 3 their mom was
still alive but the courts appointed a
male garden guardian even if the mother
was still alive
they're like so wait so nowhere if
you're a dude and you have a wife and
kids and then you die and then the kids
have to go to another dude because if
the lady can't take care of him what's
she gonna do so wait Michelle his wife
no no this is his Rachel brother I'm
sorry right Rachel's brothers dust
dies the kids go to her but they're like
there needs to be a man to watch over
the kids too
yeah and that's Andrew that's an
additional means he's now no and it's
Andrew Andrews now there's one other
percent in charge right kids
she gets she can live with him and so
because she's there you may look at them
but we're gonna go with this guy who's
got a penis like if he wanted to be like
scoot get the [ __ ] out her she what and
get out of here that's it it's me and
the boys do you have no connection to
your sons you know if you got a problem
with it bring it up on dr. Phil yeah
Andrew you're not recognizing what she's
asking of you yeah I know I don't think
her let's bring the boys out come on
heroin that's an interest out to tell
that's it that's what we call a giveaway
masturbate mmm 18 hours a day well and
you ever thought about this Andrew that
maybe sometimes when you're casting
these people to duel you're actually
shooting it yourself and you're trying
to duel the other Andrew that seems to
pull you apart from Rachel and your now
your boys yeah I think that all the time
actually I'm just gonna kill some
Cherokee you're here be honest men we'll
be right back
have you had a lot of land given to you
sparsely over the country that you wish
connected I have if so call dr. Phil
psycho weirdos very specific so another
one of Rachel's brothers his wife had
twins okay and then for some reason he
died though they gave one of them to
enter it right you did one twin away
they're like mittens no but if you have
two and you're like what if they look
alike no twins have something that we
should all strive to have if there's two
of them they look the same like I can't
tell these apart then you give one to
we're setting up act one of the Parent
Trap just give one to a friend yeah or
your brother or whatever well we didn't
bring you a bottle of wine but you want
James so they named him Andrew Jackson
jr. hey JJ but he's remembered though
they're one of the other boys Andrew
Jackson's an assignee Andrew Jackson's
living in the house and big Andy little
and your middle Andy regular Andy
regular Andy I don't know which one that
is we're all kind of regular Andy um so
over the years they would just keep
getting kids from different relatives
what was part of the chat it's not
really nonchalantly or saying that
that's not a thing it's part of it's not
like when you have like a bunch of yeah
you know go to need rehabilitation and
you open a farm you know just kinda
budget rate of know someone has twins
you gets a good one it's not a potluck
with babies I would disagree okay their
tenancy was considered the West at the
time right wild unsettled white settlers
kept pushing Native Americans off their
land to come so you know have to go
through to come so with you he's a
Native American brought up much the
tribes together great I'm good
Iroquois and he approached the British
about joining forces
so he's like hey hey you guys want to
fight the Americans the British would
supply the Native Americans with weapons
and supplies and then in turn the Native
Americans have fight the Americans and
and the British would just be like well
they are savage wrong we don't know
where they got all these lovely weapons
good Lord be terrifying it was all in
opposition
mmm-hmm care for a half boil two changes
bridge war between the US and Britain
was declared on a June 12th 1812 okay
Andrew offered his services and the 2500
volunteers in his division okay
President Madison did not at all like
Andrew because he had supported
Madison's opponent in the election sure
but soldiers were needed and ER and the
Tennessee Volunteers joined the war and
were sent to New Orleans no no no no the
soldiers returned they told they'd be
reimbursed by the government oh boy and
never gonna work out yeah sure I mean if
the government ever says we're gonna
reimburse you there's no one's gonna
reimburse you yeah back then there's
another podcast I think we did recently
with a similar part but I feel like it's
gone all right nothing so the men got on
boats and headed south okay
then enter got a message from a
Secretary of War telling him to disband
his militia and turn over quote all
articles of public property to the
commander
the south so now editors furious he went
all this way now he's given up all his
[ __ ] to another guy that he doesn't like
the guy anyway right he had used his own
then he used his own money and got I
used to buy food and supplies to get
them back home because they were all out
they were expecting to get in New
Orleans and get get all their stuff
right and then these guys took
everything they had that's cool it's a
cool situation yeah yeah sure so they
marched it 500 miles back
Jesus yeah so but again now people just
make some people like a moor in
Tennessee right and he's just guy helped
everybody out right do the thing no he
looks good because he gave up all the
weapon cuz he paid for all there oh so
now dueling is becoming less and less
popular these days
right now it's dance-offs yeah a lot of
dance offs there's some this is the
founding of getting served that's right
yeah that's what this with the story
yeah
two men Jesse Benton and William Carroll
decided to duel now Carroll asked Andrew
Jackson to be a second his second
meaning the guy so there's a duel
yeah they go hands do the gun and does
all [ __ ] so the duel is a mess Carroll
was shot in the hand and Benton was shot
in the ass oh my god
getting shot in the ass well that means
you to turn around yeah and so that's
not a good thing to go shot me yeah okay
that means you're not brave right
because your butts out right in the
direction where your face should be
least that's the tail or you're being
hilarious I'm like oh that's right yeah
you can be talking with your butt cheeks
so get in the shot I shot in the ass
huge embarrassment and meant you tried
to dodge the bullet so Jesse Benton's
brother Thomas was mad at Andrew for not
stopping the duel when the guy so he's
basically mad because the brother had
his back turned or whatever and he
didn't stop and or didn't stop his guy
from shooting he's like don't shoot him
in the butthole or whatever you call it
wait Andrew dance who was Andrews
defendant Andrews with the guy who shot
and shot the guy in the butt right yeah
and what does he pissed about
so he's mad that that the guy was turned
and hander didn't stop him from shooting
but it's an embarrassment to shoot oh
it's in a bit but it's embarrassing to
get shot in the ass but it's also
embarrassing to shoot a guy in there
I do not agree with this well in these
stupid rules of honor that make no sense
it makes complete sense well I'm gonna
I'm gonna argue the nuance so now the
two brothers Jessie and Thomas Benton
are furious with with Andrew shot in the
butt yeah okay so they keep talking [ __ ]
about him all over the place they're
talking [ __ ] about on the talking [ __ ]
about him so finally he's had enough he
finds out that they're staying at at the
city hotel in Nashville he [ __ ] rolls
down there on his horse starts walking
around he walks past the hotel he walks
back and then the brothers see him he
pulls out a whip whoa Jessie Benton and
starts shooting okay one bullet hit
enter in the left shoulder shattered
bone severed an artery the second bullet
hit his left arm Andrew got one shot off
before he went down and then all hell
breaks loose Thomas Benton starts
shooting as did John Coffey who is
Andrews friend who was there uh-huh
and then one of the Andrews nephews just
happens to be passing by he sees his
uncle down on the ground so he runs a
Jessie Benton and pulls out his knife
and just arched [ __ ] slash having him
stabbing him with a knife Jesus and then
Jessie put a gun barrel against the
nephew's hello what's the nephew like
he's probably four oh my put a nephew
against the got against the nephews
heart and pull the trigger but it
misfired Jesus and then another relative
of Andrew was cruising by Andrew
Donaldson and then he rolled up and he
started [ __ ] shooting and finally the
guys at the hotel and then people were
like [ __ ] stop you guys you're good
well that used to work yeah interesting
so they got them to stop the only person
seriously wounded was Andrew Jackson cuz
he got shot twice and an artery yeah he
was taking ten I bet the nephews hand
heard from stabbing yeah yeah that that
can really risk
yeah carpal tunnel yeah
so he's taken to an inn where he just
basically ruined two mattresses by
bleeding into them so that's bad that's
probably a lot of blood tell you who he
calls Ghostbusters no Casper yeah that's
how it goes getting mattresses by the
way yeah
doctors came and they said the left arm
had to come off well really gotta cut
that [ __ ] [ __ ] off and and ER was
like no I'm not that's not me that's not
who I am okay
I'm not not down with that and they're
like we are gonna die and he goes if I
get and let it happen [ __ ] you're not
reading anymore I know I'm improvising
yeah that little I'm assuming this is
exactly how the Commerce I know the
Breaking Bad style was in then so they
put on slippery elm which is obviously
hunt slip is that that's a guy to get on
let me get on you know it was a record
oh let's look for him yeah hey we're
mostly acoustic and then they put on
other natural cures which are all Native
American remedies Ronnie the bleeding
finally stopped and the next morning was
like he's gonna live dudes gonna [ __ ]
live with his arms so but for weeks he
could barely move and people ran the
Benton brothers brothers out of town
everyone's like we love Andrew go
[ __ ] again not reading maybe most
people thought Andrew was an idiot to
get involved in duels of this at his age
they're like dude I love this don't know
why they were thinking that well I mean
24 is dying
it's like 18 13 so when did I say he was
born yes 717 1767
okay so he's 40s maybe shouldn't be
shooting yeah Brad Street yeah right
yeah don't you Bros on the street is the
name of a charity album so in the summer
of 1813 affection of Creek Indians
called Red Sticks
okay started fighting against regular
creeks the regular creeks were more
assimilated assimilated into white
society okay so these guys the red
sticks didn't like the the more
I don't know what they would call it
civilize back man but it's simulated
they were more like dressing like the
whites and living in houses like the
whites and more you know shitty shitty
people the red six are called red sticks
because they painted their worklet clubs
back bright red okay so five hundred and
fifty three white men women and children
sought refuge at Fort Mims and then a
thousand painted mostly naked red stick
select dick says the sticks are gonna
get a little red or anybody's yeah
something else going on right now
the red sticks attacked and slaughtered
every white person that they could only
thirteen people escaped okay so a lot of
that's what five hundred not identified
over five pregnant women had infants cut
from their wombs she's every white
person was scalped so the red sticks
came to [ __ ] party like they were like
let's do let's do it or we'll do it
completely let's have some fun out there
I bet when they were coming over the
wall they were like balls to the wall
let's go balls to the wall guys we're
going all the way rock out rock out
let's do this [ __ ] on three ready red
sticks so the so that now the Tennessee
Volunteers were like we should probably
do something about that run so they're
called in a service Andrew put it an ad
in the paper
murderers needed already already they
advanced towards your frontier with
their scalping knives unsheath to
butcher your wives your children and
your helpless babes time helpless
behaves yeah time is not to be lost the
health of your general is restored he
will command in person but his health
was not restored he was not it was
healthy enough to run it was still me
yeah he sent a lot of pain still his
left arm not usable okay and all he had
to be helped on to his horse he needs
help too right and couldn't feed himself
it sounds like they are most sort of off
pieces of bone quote came out of my arm
came out of his arm and when they did he
would send them to Rachel as a souvenir
really sweetheart he told her quote I
hope all the loose pieces of bone are
out and I shall not be long
to paint longer paint with it so you
just had a situation where bowling how
you keep a girl yeah I that's how I got
my first girlfriend these are still
coming out oh wait no more
I still have bone coming out of me
really miss you miss us said anyway he
just everyone send her bone and be like
that came out hey look at that and it
was always very thin and may have been
infected with intestinal parasites since
childhood that were common in the
Carolinas at the time he had chronic
diarrhea
during the can I imagine was just called
bowel movement yeah probably during the
Greek campaign he could barely sit up on
the March he would lean forward in his
saddle as though hugging his horse so
this is the fearless leader the man who
has one arm that works one dead one
can't stop [ __ ] on his horse that
he's hugging as he rides yeah
follow him that's that guy but maybe
this time the other guys are all
probably worse is the 1820s or whatever
so it's symptoms jump out come out put
that in an envelope all right
he still had the bullet in him the
bullets never came out
so led from the bullets leached into his
bloodstream he had symptoms consistent
with lead poisoning they had an
abdominal cramping nausea headaches
constipation that would alternate with
diarrhea so he had that constipation I
think that double down yeah because he
also double diarrhea from the other
things not reading I'm go to medical
school now total diary is a thing no
it's also the area around the bullets
never fully healed so he had chronic
low-grade infection which left him
susceptible to other infections and
sometimes he just coughed up blood is it
safe to say Andrew Jackson's dying and
nobody's great at parties I got a mail
that to my wife take that bone out while
I share weight mail the [ __ ] to your
wife now don't be weird the bones okay
what about the blood the blood mail to
her too and then save some for me I'm
gonna put it in my hair
I can't stop must be something I didn't
eat now give me a favor put some bactine
in these wounds actually man the wound
of my wife oh god I got a [ __ ] more
bring the [ __ ] in here I need to hug
him put something in me you're awful I'm
leaking from shoulder to bottom you
should be a senator I will be and you're
uh so anyway back to the fighting the
Red Sticks okay so at a creek town
Andrews men slaughter at a hundred and
seventy-six people and took 80 prisoners
okay and ER took a baby and sent that
baby home to Rachel de Rais hey it's
bone sort of so this is apparently
common to just male babies no he would
just take a baby and then that baby
wouldn't be raised as a native America
will be raised as a white person so it
was like then they'd be like that one's
fine yeah it's all normal Davy Crockett
was at the attack and he said quote we
shot them like dogs
Davy finished writing the song we got to
go
hold on Andrew got the nickname sharp
knife that's when the Native Americans
started calling him sharp knife okay not
a good nickname no Andrew attacked more
red sticks at talaq talaq a yes sure
killing 300 but now his men were over it
they were hungry and thought they should
be discharged because they had served an
entire year
Andrew is like you want to know what
pain is but ander said that they had in
Serbia cuz they had gone back home and
and then taking time off before they
went back out so he said they still had
another six months to go cuz they had
because there was nothing there was no
war on at that point whatever he's tried
to shoot them if they tried to leave in
one group still want to leave so he had
the artillery pointed at them and then
he also stood in the line of fire it
said weird twist yeah and then the guys
said quote let us stay please that's how
you change in a database why did he stay
in front of it he was like I'll die too
yeah he was like [ __ ] it let's all go
honestly I'd be nice to just have a day
away from the toilet I just want to stop
[ __ ] four years after Tennesseans
told the awesome story of the time
Andrew Jackson's threatened to blow
himself up and his men to put down a
mutiny
it's [ __ ] great what a great guy a
story well a quality story yeah yeah
during another battle with the Red
Sticks a friendly Cherokee leader
journalist saved Andrews life Creek
Indian was about to kill him when a
journalist drove his tomahawk through
the Creek warriors skull Wow
around at that fight around 800 red
sticks were killed 300 women and
children were captured and I wrote a
letter to Rachel quote the carnage was
dreadful
phones on route all by me horrible
though he had his men count the dead and
to avoid double counting they cut off
the tip of each Red Sticks nose it's
just easier to count that way if you
have a pocket full of nose and nasal
scalping yeah well I mean it's easier
then because otherwise you're like okay
well yeah we're we have 43 but if you're
otherwise you go just count the noses in
your pocket all right
84 noses the soldiers also sliced sliced
off long strips of skin to make bridle
reins I just threw up in my face what a
tidal range yeah like for horses uh I
think I think people are awful good
point that I would look just at least I
didn't say bacon you know I mean we got
a little bit of a break there a little
bit of a break yeah but you still sent
bacon this was a big battle in the war
because the British were close to
supplying the hostile tribes with
weapons so on the March back Andrew
burned every native village he came
across and then he destroyed the Creek
food supply so both V friendly the Red
Sticks
and the sorry both the hostile the red
sticks and the friendly ones who had
been fighting them we're now on the
verge of starvation cool guy yeah yeah
it's a regular non red stick Creek was
helping them write me helping them out
but now he's like [ __ ] you guys buck
twister is like Andrew was made
major-general
I was it was already Major General I
miss been a mistake now he's
major general general no part of his job
was negotiating a peace settlement with
the creeks he came up with a plan
I bet it's bad no he kicked the hostile
creeks off their land and made them move
in with the friendly creeks see Mark
Burnett problem so wait he's just the
hell mate he's a that'll be more land
for the white people and then he's
making all the Native Americans that go
out scholars they're gonna find issue
with well so that was weird cuz the all
these creeks would just help him fight
the Red Sea like by having to live with
the Red Sticks who they just fought
against awkward so super super cool but
then still you're gonna get on the same
page eventually and be like yeah let's
kill hydrogen yeah yeah yeah that's way
to go at this time Florida was claimed
by both the United States and Spain okay
why I don't know yeah neither should
have it Andrew heard the British were
dropping supplies at Pensacola which was
occupied by Spain and he has for
permission to take troops down and take
care of that situation okay and
President Madison was like no just just
can you chill for a minute how about you
[ __ ] you just settle down a little in
seconds how about you relax for 10 sec
he'll out you have enough noses so he
just said he said just get some
intelligence find out what's going on
stay off Spanish soil right so Andrew
started sending letters to Spanish
comandante Gonzales in Pensacola okay
they just basically talking [ __ ] through
letters yeah it's tweeting he wrote yeah
it's tweeting he wrote Gonzales that he
better not be harboring Indians or the
British he wrote that the Spanish had
sheltered quote murderous barbarous
rebellious Bandini
Andrew then called up his militia which
was what the president said not to do
right now it seems like he's definitely
not listening to orders word then came
that British Rear Admiral Cockburn had
burned hello I'm the Rear Admiral names
Cockburn Oh yuck it up [ __ ] well
it's funny because yeah I understand but
it's funny because I've also taken male
lovers your name is [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
like a gonorrhea Phil [ __ ] yeah and I'm
the Admiral of the rear thank you I
didn't want to say it but you're yes yes
a bottom and I've taken male lovers yeah
yet I've gotten burning [ __ ] from oh
we're trying to insinuate that there's
no need to insinuate what happened I'll
be honest I'm in an unfulfilled marriage
and recently I've taken to having sex
with some of the men so it's now
laughing up if you must that I've gotten
gonorrhea from a few of those boys but
that's right the rear admiral who likes
to be the admiral of the rear whose last
name is Cockburn has a burning [ __ ] now
I'm too goddamn business just from there
the jokes been made boys just in the
troops perspective all the fellas out
here we yeah they're just hoping to have
a little fun with that and now it's more
like a medical lecture have fun if you
want but gentlemen I'm telling you I am
head-to-toe gonorrhea I've got a rear in
a trench coat
so we're just gonna take off and
everybody we're gonna go find another
Rear Admiral yeah get yourself and I
love this marriage see what happens to
you okay you're bad person you stick
around and er wanted to do something
after the white house was burned down
because that's not cool right so he took
his troops at Regular Army Tennessee
Mississippi militia large pan Choctaw
Indians and headed for Pensacola okay
this was a direct violation of madison's
order I think it said pleat violated
said don't go to Pensacola alright this
troops oh my go
he sent a message to commandant Gonzales
demanding he turned over the fort okay
Lincoln's office was like no okay I'm
not gonna know right
and then Anders troops stormed the storm
Pensacola and Gonzales surrendered but
that was just the town the Spanish
officer at the fort rejected the
surrender he's like oh my I'm down sign
up yeah he was like Gonzales this is a
[ __ ] idiot right and so Andrew started
attacking the fort then the British blew
it up so it couldn't be taken over
they're like [ __ ] this nice British yeah
yeah we kind of have it nobody can
happen nobody will play so and then went
to Andrew they went to New Orleans
British gunboats were on a nearby lake
and he declared martial law in New
Orleans although he had no authority to
do that and I don't think they ever
overturned it
on December 24th a treaty was signed in
Belgium ending the war okay but there's
no phones or anything so so it takes a
minute no texting so it would have to be
ratified by the US government before was
officially over which would happen on
February 16th 1815 but no one in the
area knew right now that was what was
habit right so they kept fighting the
British attacked and Andrew won big time
like big time just [ __ ] slaughtered
the British several high-ranking British
officers were killed the troops rendered
hundreds of British were dead just
laying in the [ __ ] swamps like they
would find bones for like another
hundred years and [ __ ] well I know what
to mail from yeah girl the victory of
New Orleans was celebrated across the
country he was called the green
backwoodsmen and had bested the
invincible British so people loved it
they're like just [ __ ] great you
slaughtered a bunch of the Brits [ __ ]
awesome we love that I love that about
you like it's awesome you come out of
the woods they're like oh the pudding or
whatever
I mean pudding you know people in New
Orleans are like let's get back to our
lives like it's all over that should
happen let's [ __ ] get back to lid
let's make we're inks and boots but
Andrew kept martial law in effect okay a
member of the Louisiana Legislature
published an article complaining about
Andrews abuse of power a keeping martial
law in effect so Andrew had had him
arrested to prove that he was during
martial law to prove that he wasn't
abusing power yet the metal show yep and
then the light legislator appealed to a
federal judge Hall who upheld the appeal
and sent Andrew a writ of hey
his corpus he's like [ __ ] knock that
[ __ ] off okay wrap it up right and ER
then seize the judge for a bedding and
ordered him marched four miles outside
of the city and release okay like a dog
that you don't want yeah yeah he just
gonna have a marched out and drop down
go on swamp or whatever you don't have
to it's kind of a life sentence go time
well don't just stand there with those
puppy-dog eyes leave get outta here yeah
judge you like Florida start walking
you'll find a new home you'll find
someone who loves you you'll find a
courthouse why are you whispering gavel
because I've grown attached to you over
that four mile ride yeah you're my
favorite judge yet thank you get have
you seen bat lose head Oh family sent to
and the ones that like has nothing to do
with you want to talk anymore are we
done now I don't blew it bad lieutenant
- yeah nobody hasn't bench that deep get
out of here it's there's a dance number
what mm-hmm later okay heretic but word
came word came that now word comes
finally the treaties been ratified right
good news and ER then ends martial law
he's like all right I guess that's that
judge halt judge Hall was allowed back
into the city hey hey sorry awkward but
as soon as you got back into court he
ordered Andrew there to explain why he
should not be held in contempt of court
martial laws back on and ER came but
refused to answer questions and then the
judge fined him $1,000 which and you're
paid okay when he stepped out of the
courtroom a enormous crowd cheered him
right yeah America Android then returned
home but it was a long trip because
everyone wanted to see him quote he was
feasted caressed and I may say idolized
they took upon him as a strange prodigy
and women children and old men lie in
the road to look at him as though they
would an elephant so he's now a hero
nationwide elephant okay as part of the
Treaty of
and Andrews ordered to remove white
settlers from Native American
territories in southern Tennessee and
northern Mississippi and a refuse yeah I
was gonna say it doesn't sound like his
MO no that's not really his jam so he
just refused the what they call the law
right order the law he was so popular
could get away with it though yeah
Madison didn't want to fire him and
alienate voters that I mean we we can
trace it all the way back we're talking
about at this time in Florida the
Seminoles were made up of an alliance of
earlier tribes and people who weren't
like traditional Native Americans
including Creoles and runaway slaves
it's just like a big sure mishmash
appeal or a ragtag right during the War
of 1812 they had built a makeshift fort
and they were now around 300 and they
had quote a large quantity of British
muskets powder and other supplies nice
so the Secretary of War told Andrew to
warn the Spanish governor at Pensacola
to clean out the fort or let the United
States do it okay so the Spanish
governor is like go go for it out not to
Godspeed not to shit's [ __ ] care so
Andrew had a gunboat sent and the
gunboat that's a boat shaped like a gun
right it's a bush shaped like a gun we
don't have those anymore but they used
to be your the floating it used to be
also goat shaped like guns
goats mm-hmm my dad was a farmer but
those maybe a whiskey farmer and they
made those illegal because you know last
time together Feinstein's we're gun no
no no Dave wrong episode completely
three ago so so they start shooting at
each other the fort and the gunboat and
they shot a they started firing heated
so they would heat up cannonballs until
they were glowing she's and then they
would shoot them yeah that's my balls
work that's just slice through some yeah
well like that's a hot ball you just
kind of guys in the Ford Yellin ha
so the rear Admirals like I understand
what that feels like
those are my genitals okay can you go
back in here I've enjoyed mail many
lovers go back in your room absolutely
I'll go back in my room I'm sitting in
an ice bath because boy it's like
someone put hot coals on my penis whoo
you know Rear Admiral we're going to a
doctor yeah
I don't trust quacks so one hot one of
these flaming glowing hot balls landed
in a gunpowder stockpile Oh God and the
Ford exploded and everybody died oh my
god
all the seminoles inside does Jesus so
that an ending that was not expected
right so there's peace for a little
while and then the seminoles started
raiding again there's more out there
right so I rating there might be a
little angry now now there you know it's
escaped slaves it's Native Americans
smugglers pirate yes it's just all kinds
of people so and ER told President
Monroe he wanted to go into Florida and
take care of business it's like it's
good some [ __ ] chicken yes TCB so
Monroe said would later say he didn't
authorize the attack and ant Andrew
Jackson would say he got a letter from a
congressman that authorized the attack
but also told him to burn it so you go
with whoever you think is I'll go with
the non Andrew Jackson yeah that's
probably so and are headed to Florida
basically to take care of the Native
American Seminole problem and then he
started rolling through and killing
Indians everywhere including a group of
creeks what started as a guys to rest
Seminoles was turning into a full-scale
war an occupation in Florida so he
[ __ ] goin ape [ __ ] down there he
recaptured Pensacola that the Spanish
had and put American troops in the fort
the Spanish are now furious sure some
Americans worried that Andrew had the
makings of a dictator he was violating
international law yeah he executed two
British citizens and the English press
were tapes it calling him quote a Yankee
pirate with blood on his hands
well this is before the Daily Mirror had
puns that's right in in DC they thought
he was trying to start a war with Spain
so he got a bludgeon
so he could invade Mexico okay I call it
DC but it's probably just Washington but
I'd rather call it DC because it's
shorter
he had basically declared war without
congressional approval he was portrayed
as as was that he'll obviously was
portrayed as aiding aided by squatters
so they were they were in the news they
were portraying him as a device quater
squatters like the lowest of the low
right of white men anyway as they say
who were dressed up as quote white
savages
after his run through Florida was done
Munro returned the fort's to the Spanish
to avoid war and later a treaty was
signed in the u.s. got Florida and Spain
got Texas okay now back in DC people
want an investigation they're like what
the [ __ ] happened with you in Florida
they did that [ __ ] was crazy doesn't
matter the Spanish got what they wanted
it's fine no you went bug you want bugs
far you went [ __ ] bugs bugs [ __ ] you had
fatback's know that you literally define
bugs like we didn't have that word
before you went down to Florida Lee went
bug [ __ ] man I had some fun what can I
say it's not fun that's do you killed a
bunch of [ __ ] people in the name of
justice hello
good lord so Henry Clay demanded censure
Andrew Jackson told all the legal
authorities it was between him and
President Monroe and nobody else all
right
he also threatened to cut off the ears
of some senators because they dared to
investigate and humiliate him on the
national stage didn't like ears didn't
cut your ears out not a non linear fan
or noses so he had a got a mouth out but
it's already a halt you can cut him out
huh Oh God he had a simple explanation
of his actions against the Native
Americans it was quote the right of
retaliatory vengeance against inhumane
bloody barbarians
so yeah cause I right also yeah yeah the
aggressor they were living there yeah
yeah okay like if you came and moved
into my bedroom
might be man you've been a real dick
Dave yeah we're trying to sleep in here
okay your head off no my ears after
Florida huge financial downturn came and
people moved west looking for a new
start Andrew Jackson had his government
salaries so he built the new home on his
Hermitage property that's what he called
this joint sure the old home became
slave quarters he now owned around four
dozen slaves right good guy he's just
rolling and rolling people I'm calling
it in 1821 the u.s. decided to shrink
the size of the army but no one wanted
to tell Andrew to retire because he was
a [ __ ] lunatic yeah so they made him
governor of Florida okay sure sure a
role that would be held by a lunatic
until today so Andrew and Rachel went to
Pensacola and dealt with the turnover
from the Spanish to the Americans until
the end of the year and then after that
he was done he turned it over to the new
governor quote I am truly wearied of
public life I want rest and my private
concerns imperiously demand my attention
his health still not great quote for
four months I have been oppressed with a
violent cough and cost eveness
constipation which i think is just
constipation constipation custard nasai
believe is just be really bad yeah like
double constipation which we talked
about earlier with the diarrhea from
1821 to 1824 he lived at home his
supporters tried kept trying to convince
him to run for president they like dude
you've got to [ __ ] do this you are so
awesome you are so the way you rolled
through Florida and that [ __ ] is off the
hook it's a good voting base too he
didn't wanna be President though he
wanted to stay at home and enjoy his
life in Tennessee Rachel really didn't
want him to be President so Andrew said
he would not campaign for the presidency
but if people elected him Oh No well
then he would be his duty to serve is
that right yeah well loophole there
feels like so he was then elected to
serve in the Senate okay
all right cuz it was done by well he
said if anybody likes me to something
more I do it cuz that's what you want
right so it gets like this time but this
time is DC was slow because
he was getting mobbed by people at every
stop
he's just if people just [ __ ] apeshit
right he's this huge hero he had to
switch from horseback to a stagecoach
coach to keep from being recognized what
and had to get out this lone horse like
that's how he's like Jim Carrey in the
[ __ ] 90s yeah he's like Sanjaya so
good he did not like being senator
though he thought it was tedious it was
mostly boring speeches and socializing
he also did not fit in in Washington DC
at all he was a huge [ __ ] one
congressman described him as quote
uncouth looking uncouth looking Thomas
Jefferson thought Andrew had savage
instincts and once observed him so
overcome with anger that he was left
speechless
okay now the time speechlessness was
considered the trait of a primitive man
okay his fiery temple permanently marked
him with the elites of DC so he's like
he's like they seem as an uncontrollable
uncouth force dude not a force but then
down okay so they're not worried about
him they're just like get out of here
yeah they think he's a [ __ ] idiot
okay
and it was blunt with his opinions and
also took quick resentment to anyone who
disagreed with his opinions a few months
later he went back to Nashville and his
supporters still want him to be
President in 1824 Andrew Jackson got 154
thousand votes John Quincy Ansel Adams
got a hundred nine thousand votes a
representative Henry Clay and secretary
of the Treasury William H Crawford got
forty-seven thousand eight now I did
mean he was president okay so the
electors met in DC in December for two
weeks no wonder the president would be
Andrew to DC Rachel came with him this
time now he wants to be President I
think I want this [ __ ] when the
electoral vote came in it was Andrew
Jackson 99 Adams 84 Crawford 47 clay 37
but the Constitution said if no
candidate had a majority of votes the
house would choose the president from
the top three writers so clays fourth so
he's out
right so now it's between Crawford Adams
and Jackson and I remember all these
guys don't [ __ ] like him right
Clay's a harvard-educated dude he
doesn't like the [ __ ] Western country
bumpkin he's a member of House of
Representatives he didn't like any of
the choices quote I consider it whatever
choice we make will be only a choice of
Evil's so he made a deal with John
Quincy Adams Adams would make him
Secretary of State if he swung the vote
to Adams and that's not John Quincy
Adams became the sixth President of the
United States okay Andrew Jackson is
[ __ ] furious okay because he won the
vote yeah but he didn't get elected
imagine winning the popular vote and
nothing the president oh my god yeah I
can't he resigned this he resigned from
the Senate again in return in Nashville
President John Quincy Adams was not
Andrew Jackson he was a loner who
abstained from pleasure and vices
he rose well before dawn every morning
to read the Bible in Greek German French
in English Oh God
wait good lord I mean you're really
hedging your bets on God there's got to
get him on all right just in case he's
German he walked for exercise and
calculated the distance walked he'd
measure his stride at two feet six and
eighty-eight hundredths of an inch so I
mean on the spectrum right yeah
insane before Adams was even inaugurated
the Nashville Gazette declared Andrew a
candidate for president in 1828 okay so
they're looking forward to the next port
right they didn't ask him they just did
it and that's what happened and it
turned into an ugly campaign clay called
Andrew a dangerous military chieftain
which is another way of saying back then
a savage right and his friends brought
bata newspapers to make sure the
propaganda went their way okay Anders
opponents charged him with Negro
speculation which is also known as slave
trading which for some reason owning
slaves was okay but trading them was not
oh you're such a [ __ ] stupid
courageous
just so [ __ ] soon no no no rules are
rules
you can own them you just can't trade
the much bad [ __ ] [ __ ] of you they
brought up all his duels and portrayed
him as a down and dirty street fighter
who'd stay stabbed a man in the back
with a sword hidden in his cane it's
true well his friendship with Aaron Burr
was used to suggest he was a traitor and
then they went after Rachel I kind of
remember this a little bit from the
cheese one yes some they accused and her
of stealing another man's wife right
Rachel was laid labeled an adulteress
papers called her quote a dirty black
wench an American Jezebel and weak and
vulgar Jezebel in fxj yeah that's a
really good FX show one editor said she
could no more pass in polite company
than a gentleman's black mistress just
great what another described Rachel as
fat with tanned skin who looked like an
old washer woman so being white skin
meant you didn't work but if you were
tan that mean you were a laborer so that
was an insult to say you didn't have
fair skin yeah cool cool it's cool super
cool
yeah and they made fun of her back
country divorce and the fact that she
smoked a cigar in court cob pipe so this
is the 1830s version of city liberals
making fun of the flyover state right
and it was the first Westerner that had
a chance to win the presidency
Westerners were considered squatters and
intruders back east
many had no land and were uneducated
they were looked down upon they were
considered crude boastful distrustful of
civilization and City people they had a
love of Liberty and were made fun of for
their degenerative breeding the first
time and ER had run for president it
invoked quotes he didn't he was like
Mamie
it invoked quote sneers and derision of
the men in power in Washington but now
he was a threat Americans saw him as a
man from the woods he's a force yeah who
had what it took to clean up the
corruption of Washington oh my god what
Andrew Jackson looked the stereotype of
a Western man tall lanky carried harsh
lived life on his face he was known to
who's known to get to do things without
deliberation and jet and justify his
behavior he totally lacked any statesmen
like qualities he was happy to not have
them but to those raised in the woods
and harsh lands of America he was Old
Hickory a man a self-made man who came
from rough tough woods of Tennessee they
loved his rough edges
he wasn't fancy John Quincy Adams his
foray into Florida meant he was a man
who didn't take [ __ ] his treatment of
Native Americans said he'd get done what
needed to be done yeah there's a
correlation between murder and
legislation that's never gone away no
nor it's still pure Burt oh yeah no
still yeah tough guy yeah it's like when
Ted Cruz shoots like a shotgun with
bacon on it he's like goddamn right yeah
that's totally yeah okay that matters he
was trying to make it so that I can't
shoot an Uzi with bacon on it
no thanks liberal it was and it was the
first presidential candidate to be
boosted by a campaign biography and the
first not to have the education and
breeding of the elites the biography was
said real Americans were Jacksonians not
the snobs of Washington in the eastern
cities so running an anti-corruption he
pointed to the clay Adams election mess
that had happened four years earlier
it's an example which was corrupt yeah
and Andrew won he was the first
Westerner elected president the
Jacksonians were now call himself
Democrats and gained majorities in the
House and Senate
what did it sound familiar but an event
so it's a totally different it is as if
a totally different alien force of
people have come and taken over the
government and
out of fear assimilation and they but
they've taken over all branches of the
government but it had been a brutal
election particularly for Rachel and on
December 18th she felt an excruciating
pain and the left shoulder arm and
breast for three days the doctors bled
her and on the fourth day she died
they had to pry her body away from
Andrew he blamed his opponents for her
death Jesus after a period of mourning
he came to Washington the presidency at
that time paid fifty thousand but he had
to pay for all the parties and
receptions which we've heard about and
the job also required expensive tailored
clothes his expenses were more than the
presidential salary so being a president
at that time you had to forget dish out
more money than the factors millions in
the White House so he's a populist
president obviously the previous six
presidents had been rich dudes picked by
other rich dudes while Andy was rich
owning over 100 slaves
it had [ __ ] loads of property but he was
the people's president people came to
celebrate his eggnog inauguration a
journalist quote it was like the
inundation of the northern barbarians
into Rome safe save that the tumultuous
tide came in from a different point of
the compass the West and South seemed to
have precipitated themselves upon the
north and overwhelmed it on that
memorable occasion you might tell a
Jackson man almost as far as you could
see him there every motion seemed to
outcry the victory 50,000 people watched
the inauguration speech the audience
rushed the barrier to shake his hand and
eventually had to force a path between
the people to get down I have to go to
the toilet always always someone about a
toilet you can just put on you that's
what I'm looking for my vice president
will be whoever could make a toilet that
stays on my ass when I'm walking people
streamlined in the Washington into the
White House for hours
Andrew quickly nominated his cabinet for
Secretary of War II chose John Eaton his
friend and protege John Eaton had just
married Peggy O'Neal Timberlake Peggy's
husband had just died and she didn't
wait the usual year of mourning so the
town turned against her shunning her and
calling her assi even his cabinet did
the whole affair blew up
enter Jackson's cabinet so everyone's
just calling her a [ __ ] not letting her
be part of the deal Andrew proposed
abolishing the Electoral College please
try he was also not down with the Bank
of the United States a privately owned
bank held by Richmond to control the
finances of the government aren't
selling him to me which is Alexander
Hamilton's idea you might see that in
his play but probably not
there were also big big Tara fight after
a while and your ass his entire cabinet
to resign even the VP went he finished
his first term without a vice president
oh okay
before Andrew presidents thought the
best way to deal with Native Americans
was to civilize them this led to the
five so-called civilized tribes Cherokee
Creek Chickasaw Choctaw and Seminole
previous presidents signed tons of
treaties with tribes Thomas Jefferson
had urged shopkeepers to keep the
Indians in debt so they had to agree to
land concessions that's cool right it's
cool it's cool keeping data there the
Cherokee assimilated into American life
the most they established a written
language produced books farmed created
court and school systems converted to
Christianity adopted a constitution and
elected a principal chief John Ross some
wealthy Cherokee even owned slaves and
lived on plantations they ended their
tradition of men being hunters and women
being in charge of agriculture now men
handle the agriculture and women stayed
home and baked bread and wolf cloth they
literally did every single thing asked
of them but Andrew Jackson didn't think
there was any future for Native
Americans living in the East he figured
tribes should live on federal territory
out west not in States but he said the
move would have to be voluntary no we
have ways of making it voluntary
quincenera Lee in 1828 gold was
discovered on Cherokee land
oh yes that's the worst game a chair can
you find gold you [ __ ] bury that [ __ ]
yeah
white people really wanted it it turns
out so Georgia started
we like some colors just started passing
a bunch of state laws restricting the
Cherokees rights like Cherokees couldn't
testify against whites in court that's a
pretty big one they couldn't sell land
big they couldn't mine for gold okay
on their land and couldn't probably
dissent yeah the Cherokee then claimed
exemption from state laws and the state
said no and then the tribes appealed to
the president who was like no you know I
know I hate you then I'm 820 1830 Andrew
Jackson signed the Indian Removal Act
authorization which authorized the
President to grant unsettled lands west
of the Mississippi in exchange for
existing Indian lands so a land swap
makes it sure don't have good land sure
fair not everyone agreed Henry Clay and
John Quincy Adams thought the act was a
stain on American history
they said ander was an ignoramus who had
no restraint or respect for the rule of
law well let's follow him the gates al
on December 6th 1830 the president's
second annual message to Congress began
quote it gives me pleasure to announce
to Congress that the benevolent policy
of the government steadily pursued for
nearly 30 years in relation to the
removal of Indians beyond the white
settlements is approaching to a happy
consummation consummation yeah that's
what it says
weird Cherokees the Cherokee took it to
the Supreme Court
they lost yeah yeah but then a year
later the court ruled on another lawsuit
which ruled for the Cherokee okay so
they can stay on their land according to
the okay it's brave Clarke problem was
someone will have to enforce the ruling
of the court well LLL and if there's not
a president or a body that will enforce
the ruling of the court then what does
the court's ruling mean nothing nothing
Anderson quote the decision of the
Supreme Court has fell stillborn oh
Jesus and they find that they cannot
coerce Georgia to yield its mandate so
basically [ __ ] you law right President
Andrew Jackson was saying since the
court had no way of enforce
it's mandates the president was free to
do as he pleased cool at the start of
his second term and who travelled to
England to New England to see if he
could win over people there who pretty
much hated his guts and ER was super
into slavery he owned tons of slaves and
worked with his Postmaster General to
censor anti-slavery mailings from
abolitionists he called religiously
motivated abolitionists monsters and he
criticized the anti-slavery movement as
quote the wicked design of demagogues
sells it he sells it so we have another
salesman mm-hmm however decided to give
him an honorary doctorate sure yeah okay
so they get Harvard decided to give him
an honorary doctorate because why
wouldn't will a lot of Harvard alums
looked down on Andrew considering him
rough uncouth and uneducated they were
very upset the angriest was alum John
Quincy Adams his cousin it was the
prison was the president of Harvard he
said quote as myself an affectionate
child of our alma mater
I would not be present to witness her
disgrace in conferring her highest
literacy literacy I love that I [ __ ]
that up her highest literary honors upon
a barbarian who could not write a
sentence of grammar and hardly could
spell his own name the east actually
reads dahveed Roe didn't make fun of it
it was just really knave Manny yeah
Harvard just said they did it for all
presidents and they couldn't not do it
because of partisanship sure you got to
serve him the meal and now exaggerated
Virginia a man attacked Andrew Jackson
hitting him in the face and drawing
blood
a local guy offered to kill the attacker
if Andrew would pardon him yeah you
don't know what's gonna happen to you I
mean I'm really praying and to turn him
down okay
saying no one should take revenge for
him he should do it I saw sure sure
different then silver lining
maybe now there was another financial
panic banks collapsed in New York in
philadelphia and andrew small government
love and bad monetary politics had done
their thing the recession would last
seven years in jr. in 1835 indecent and
see an out-of-work painter raised a
pistol ten feet away from and ER and
pulled the trigger the gun did not shoot
he then whipped out a second pistol and
fired but the same thing happened the
gun did not shoot no bullet came out and
are charged at him to beat him with his
cane buttock the crowd tackled him first
when police tested the guns they both
worked perfectly the assassin frequented
congressional debates and was influenced
by rhetoric he heard in the papers he
believed the president was a tyrant and
the root of all evil and had to be
eliminated oh and he thought he was heir
to the English throne
almost at us he was ruled insane and not
prosecuted the Indian Removal Act was
still being fought by the tribes you
know Luka the Native American who had
saved Andrew during the red stick war
remember the guy yeah yeah he went to
meet when they enter Jackson but after a
couple of minutes Jackson said quote sir
your audience is ended there's nothing I
can do for you try the meat loaf and
that guy said regret chief John Ross and
the majority of opposed Cherokees were
around 20,000 and number but there was a
smaller group of Cherokees around three
hundred a number who decided removal was
the way to go they got the name the
treaty party hmm the two groups did not
like each other and they both called
the leaders of the other group a
half-breed Andrew wanted the Cherokee to
sign a new treaty that would require
removal but he did not go to principle
Chief John Ross he instead approached
the treaty party right who was
represented a far far far far smaller
group Chester and they signed on may
23rd 1836 the Senate ratified it by a
single vote oh that's where the Senate
went along with it oh that's where all
the Cherokee now had a two-year deadline
to leave their ancestral homelands
after two years anyone left would be
removed by military force
John Ross explained to the US government
that the treaty party was not authorized
to sign anything for the tribe not two
ships were given yeah a new election
rolled around and Martin Van Buren was
elected he was a huge Andrew Jackson
suck-up
Anders time as president and
before his 70th birthday he went back to
Nashville crowds cheered him along the
way on the route things were not great
at the ermitage ander jr. was a bad
businessman and there were thousands in
debt and her had to sell lanes a lot of
parallels but for once in his life his
health was actually decent he credited
to his new patent medicine which
included alcohol opium and cocaine sure
recommend it to everybody shit's [ __ ]
great right
yeah sleeps conceived sleeps out sleeps
out sleep and food are gone you want to
talk about corn I would like to talk
about corn Lords great like corn or
maize mace a sneeze take a nap I'm gonna
get up and run maize you ever make a
maize out of maize imagine have you met
amazed amazed take a head of this it's
north this mm-hmm
so Van Buren vowed to continue all of
Andrew Jackson's policies which included
the Indian Removal Act the Choctaw and
Chickasaw is removed first well
contractors were hired by the government
to provide food so because they were
private contractors they cut costs and
gave the bare minimum to the tribes
right the tribes were served rancid meat
it's a good kind next the Creek and
Seminole were rounded up and moved chief
John Ross told the Cherokee to plant
crops he said if they made any
preparations to move it would be
considered acceptance of the [ __ ]
treaty so nobody made any preparations
meanwhile George was holding land
lotteries in giving their land to white
people [ __ ] just terrible
in mid-june 8 1838 mm federal troops
stormed Cherokee homes and dragged the
people out with only the clothes on
their backs some were just pulled out of
there out of the crops they were forced
into stockades at gunpoint in the melee
families were separated from each other
looters then plundered their houses
taking whatever they wanted they even
dug up Cherokee graves and took silver
jewelry the dead were buried with you
okay yeah they started to get sick in
the stockades first dysentery and fever
then measles and whooping-cough there
are about three or four deaths a day
over 30 stockades were built to house
the Cherokee in northern Carolina
Georgia Alabama and Tennessee before
moving them West do weird to put people
in
yeah imagine quote at Ross's landing the
place to which at which sorry at Ross's
landing the place to which most of the
Georgia Indians were brought the scenes
of distress defy all description in many
instances they were dragged from their
homes without change of clothing and
marched 120 or 30 miles through heat and
dust and rain and mud in many cases
barefooted lodged on the hard ground
destitute of shelter and due from dews
and rain they had of course become very
dirty and on that account
they have been approached as degraded
wretches on arriving at the Depot they
were required to give up their horses
and ponies which they brought along
refusing to do so men women and children
and horse were driven promiscuously into
one large pen made for the purpose the
horses were then taken by force and
auctioned off to the highest bidder and
sold for almost nothing hmm good thing
over that kind of thing they would be
marched to the Indian Territory now
called Oklahoma summer was a terrible
time to travel so Chief John Ross
appealed to the government to suspend
the removals until September nope yeah
well if the government agreed he
promised the Cherokee would self remove
and the government agreed so chief Ross
was looking at moving 13,000 people 800
miles chief Ross organized 13
detachments of about a thousand people
each would have a physician and
interpreter a wagon master and a
chemistry chemistry agent so one doctor
for the Osmond people on August 28th
1838 the first attachment left Georgia
710 people Moses most of them walked
almost all walked along the way there
were nine births fifty-four deaths and
24 Runaways they walked through the heat
the rain and through snow their clothing
was soaked when it rained this would be
called the Trail of Tears estimates of
the dead are between two and five
thousand Cherokee either way an insanely
high number for 13,000 people many died
in the stockades before they ever left
Georgia others died when they arrived in
Indian Territory in the spring of 1839
the last attachment arrived in Oklahoma
on the trip Ross buried his wife in a
shallow grave along the trail she given
up her only blanket to a young girl and
then fell ill Ross arrived to an area
dominated by Native Americans who had
been moving west as early as 1807
the government was established
by the treaty party and others who had
already arrived chief Ross came with a
reunification plan for a new government
the old settlers and the treaty party
rejected the plan
Ross's group believed the treaty party
were prevented were preventing
reunification efforts so on June 22nd
1839 one of the leaders was dragged from
his bed and stabbed to death in his yard
another was ambushed and shot another
attack with knives and tomahawks his
skull broken and his body mutilated
Cherokee law stated that any man who
ceded land without Indian government
consent was subject to the death penalty
25 million acres had been stolen from
Native Americans that's a lot if you
think about it if your it was like most
not horrible or whatever so in 1845 good
day Andrew Jackson died his funeral was
held at the Hermitage - I'm placing that
wrong people gonna laugh me but you know
you're all jerks 2,500 to 3,000 people
attended his funeral
he was buried next to Rachel on the
grounds his death was big manly male
there all his bones his death is a big
deal around the country I'll see if I
can get this to go right okay so though
they had a they had a obviously a big
thing in Washington for him a procession
the poor crowded along a street it was
neither crackers or squatters lining up
to see the last hoorah vult hickory
instead it was quote poor white trash
who pushed the poor colored folk out of
the way to get a glimpse of the fallen
President and I was printed in a paper
and that white trash had appeared in
print as early as 1820 well but white
trash then became popular and a good way
after the parade no not in a good way
no white trash was like a term for white
trash for Andrew Jackson's fall right
for a white trash interesting yeah
when Donald Trump took office he added a
portrait of a nur Jackson his favorite
President to the Oval Office a couple
months later he visited the airmen
Tianjin Tennessee on November 17 2007
Trump at a ceremony honoring Navajo code
talkers he did it in the Oval Office
right in front of the painting of Andrew
Jackson quote I just want to thank you
because you are very very special people
you were here long before any of us were
here although we have a representative
Congress this is the lowest who has been
here a long time longer than you they
call her Pocahontas
then he turned one of the honorees and
said quote but you know what I like you
you are special people you stop being
funny and and yeah no wonder why oh my
god it's so hard man I was there's
something I saw in the past couple days
where it was like deep depression is
like at the highest level it's been yeah
and like you know I just it is hard it
is it is hard to to hear so because yeah
because intimidation and popularity for
whatever reason in this country will
prevail mm-hmm and and we've been here
we've done this before and we've been
doing it repeatedly like this is it like
people like chump came from out of
nowhere no I didn't it happened before
yeah and all the reasons why it happened
are still there boy that clipper he says
they call her Pocahontas but you I like
you so good it's the same guy you know
making fun of his speech yeah I'm down
on him it's all there it's all the same
stuff
yeah he's a guy who gets my hair he uses
terror the difference with people
depends it's all the same the difference
is that Andrew Jackson would leave
office um oh sorry this Thursday night
I'll be at the sycamore Tavern for a
show at 8:00 p.m.
called thirsty Thursdays and
Letterman Ryan Sickler will be there
just want to end on a really positive
note
no we're also gonna be doing a benefit
for rent control in Glendale California
on July 17th
I won't you won't be the doll but we'll
be doing stand-up in Glendale give you
the date to come but it's on July 7 -
yeah meaning you and there will be other
people join us all right well I hope
everybody feels good and is happy and
feels positive and you know things are
fine and we're gonna be good and I think
we should just say you know everything
is fine and everything is good and
anybody who worries that things aren't
good and fine you know just remember
it's fine and everything's okay good
fine and fun and fun and I think bit of
the fun cuz it's also fun and fine and
good and fun and and and fine and
everything's good and don't worry things
are fine things are good and we'll
assign cars and we're on tour and things
are good and things are fine and don't
worry about a thing and and yeah I think
they're just good so we'll see yeah
thanks for listening this is the dahle
fest for Dave Anthony things are good
I'm Gareth Reynolds some people call me
Gary it's actually Garrett things are
fine and don't worry everything is gonna
work out and we're gonna be fine and
it's good and thank you